China's leaders appear to have learned
an important lesson from SARS don't try
to cover it up so this time honesty has
been the strategy that's what President
Xi Jingping has been demanding from his
officials especially in the city of
Wuhan where the virus first emerged in
late November and this time China does
appear better prepared across the border
in Hong Kong where 300 people died
during the SARS outbreak important
lessons also appear to have been learned
all arriving airport passengers have
their temperatures checked suspected
virus sufferers are immediately
quarantined those who refused face jail
and there's better protection for
medical workers eight of whom were
killed by SARS beyond nurse arm 17 years
ago when you are working in those normal
medical ward or surgical ward no one
rare mask today wearing a face mask is
standard procedure but some things
haven't changed the market believed to
be the source of the virus is now closed
but the trade in wild animals goes on
elsewhere in China at Chinese New Year
17 years ago when the SARS epidemic was
just starting to take its toll the mood
was very subdued it is today and the
question then as now is this how worried
should I be China's failure to be open
about the SARS outbreak damaged its
international reputation which is why
the leadership hopes to convince the
international community that it's
unprecedented containment measures are
working but some Hong Kong medical
experts remain skeptical I don't think
they have much improvement in this
aspect personally I think even if it may
even more window-dressing them before
baby because of the political climate in
mainland China
analysts say President Xi Jingping is
confronting a huge challenge that what
is already a testing time for his
leadership so people realize also that
sujin pain is a top leader with power
highly concentrated in his hands and he
basically has to be responsible for all
achievements and setbacks experts say
this new disease may be harder to
control for one important reason said
19 years ago few Chinese traveled
overseas today they fly to destinations
around the world Adrian Brown al Jazeera
Hong Kong